your guys here but he works here more
and gets a bigger paycheck therefore you
know I worked here more but I the way
he's talking Fox pays him more though
the host of Fox NFL Sunday NFL on Fox
and now the new canine competition
series America's top dog that day B's
Wednesday 9:00 Eastern and Pacific good
to see the Curt Matt always good to see
you rich right back at you
we were just chit-chatting with the TV
audience now the radio audience is back
the playoffs
for me is it's exciting it there's also
a tinge of just you know depression
knowing that the end is coming yes but
it's a long slog of a season there's a
lot going on it's it's uh it's a long
season but I do love you know the
playoffs they don't work this is it now
the way this is often you know because
you get in the regular season and we
build up must-win games
well it seems got to win this week or
else right they lose that week and then
they come back in their Philadelphia and
they win their last four and they're in
the playoffs you know what I mean so
there truly is until you get to that
last week in or out no must-win game
there's need to win games right now
they're all must win well there is no
you could play the best game you lose in
a field goal the end you're done you're
talking about it next year you're the
Minneapolis miracle you know those kinds
of things where gosh we're so close and
people never live that down sometimes
right this is where legacies are made in
both good and bad ways and we will get
to see it play out in real time and
that's why I mean sports are these the
ultimate drama show it really is night
this is your you said 14th season on the
NFL on in the studio right that did
games for ten years before that is
fright Utah I'm an old-timer over there
are that I don't recall the last time
though that a wild card Saturday was one
conference in a wild card Sunday was I
don't remember ever being really it
mixes Apple oh one from each conference
each day and I think that was kind of
the expectations we had at Fox knowing
you know we were gonna show a game right
this weekend going in
and then all of a sudden we get the
announcement that you know both AFC
games would be Saturday both NFC on
Sunday obviously we were going to do an
NFC game so I think that surprised
everyone but I don't ever remember that
being like this so that gave you it
gives you day often off one of those
days either way and it's good oh that's
right this weekend we get either
Saturday or Sunday because NBC's
involved now that's right you know and
then it's the same way yeah and the next
week we alternate some years we get
Saturday and Sunday is way deepen in the
weeds and now that the Duke seven
o'clock Eastern every single Thursday
night to kick off the NC double-a
tournament it's it's like Houston being
a date for the first wildcard weekend
game see what you're like okay well
there's the early game Saturday yeah
that's right that's Houston versus the
pills let's ask the poll question of
Curtis to launch this conversation
certainly we're talking about the wild
card Curt Menefee here from Fox and also
a inane go for it Chris yeah Curt which
wild card road team do you like most to
make a deep run of the playoffs run deep
boy divisional weekend Titans Viking Sea
Hawk which one well here's the thing I
think the bills will win this weekend
okay I think Seattle has a very good
shot at winning this weekend but I think
both those teams would lose next weekend
you do yeah I think that they are part
three I think Seattle is like
Philadelphia there's running our bodies
you know now obviously the deeper you
get into the playoffs the more chance
that you have to get parties back I just
don't know if you can sustain that and
you know the way the playoffs are built
and the way you have to play games and
they're all so close now Seattle that's
it there's seven and one on the road
this year
theyõre I think ten and two in one score
games which is amazing first of all to
have 12 of the many yeah right let you
win ten of and if you go back Russell
Wilson it's not all the quarterback I'm
not old you win it's the quarterback you
lose it's not I hate those W genell's
right but in the seven years you've been
there they're an under 500 teams in one
score games until this year now all of a
sudden they're ten and two the magic is
there so that could be the team I guess
if they
one they could go deep in the playoffs
because of the way they have played and
because of the way they're used to
playing close games but I think they
would have a hard time because if they
win I means the next week they go to San
Francisco again and I don't know I just
think San Francisco's the best team in
the industry although New Orleans is one
I don't know if there's even one a is
like one double-a they're so close well
I mean there were only the third team in
the current playoff format to win 13
games and not have a bye week yeah you
know so that said maybe they're this
they're the reason why nobody's talking
about the Vikings but that's just a way
for me to be polite about percussion and
you know we had cam we had we had cam
Jordan on and you know he's dynamite
interview waiting to do this as soon as
he's done so I asked him you know you
know the the significance of this
weekend may be about what type of Dalvin
cook he's gonna say hmm and his response
was yeah but it also may be the Kirk
Cousins were gonna say I saw that okay
and then I'm numb you know mandated is
we heard of course follow up what do you
mean by that and he's just like well you
know sometimes you he will be a
proficient quarterback mm-hmm he's from
Cal so you loved it I think that's fair
but this could be we're sitting you're
saying and I agree with the bills can
win the suit
Seahawks can go on a run you know the
Titans if it wasn't just the Brady
Belichick mystique we would be sitting
here doing the plusses and minuses and
the pros and cons and saying oh
Tennessee's got a really great job this
we can animate any and it it does nobody
sent you're saying okay maybe Kirk
Cousins goes on this Nick Foles magic
carpet ride he's got that three-year
guaranteed contract and everybody talks
about because it's the only one of its
kind maybe he lives up to it right now
nobody's saying I know that's the game
that's on Fox which means we've got an
hour pregame show and as a host of a
pregame show you know we will sell you
as to how I please have a shot because
obviously they do but if you look at
right now and you look at the NFC
playoffs I mean I think San Francisco is
the best team that's why they're the
number one seed okay New Orleans is
right behind and I think it doesn't
really matter who would have to go into
New Orleans this weekend it would be
almost impossible for that team to win
and the way the Vikings finished down
the stretch there that
Green Bay maybe there as well but you
scratch your head and what can you count
on
especially if Dalvin cook snot a hundred
percent right you know are you gonna
count on the quarterback being
consistent that defense which you
thought they could hang their head on
was kind of shaky at times down the
stretch and so you go all of that on the
road at New Orleans where the Saints are
humming right now drew Brees last month
15 touchdowns zero interceptions you
know they're averaging over 34 points a
game down the stretch I mean I think
they're a buzz saw
right now they doesn't really matter who
goes in there and with the negatives we
talked about with Minnesota I don't
think there's a reason to jump on their
bandwagon other than the fact that
Jimmie Johnson and the guys will sell
you on and on Sunday Curt Menefee here
on the Rich Eisen show and and the
Packers man I mean they were one inch
shy in game 256 of having the 1 seed and
everybody in the NFC having to go
through Lambeau Field have you seen a
team that's you go back to 13 and 3 that
people have less confidence in well
here's the way that the Packers season
for me is can be summed up and and how
absolutely overlooked there is that
Rodgers in many people's minds isn't as
as lead as he more as he usually okay
he's not just taking the team and
throwing it on his back and back
shoulder throwing his way down the field
anymore and you know and bits basically
saying screw it I'm just gonna take it
and it's gonna be on my back and we're
gonna win it through my force of will
and talent and that said Matt Lafleur
gets no credit or Rogers not having to
do that and he and Lafleur gets no
credit for being coach of the year
because Aaron Rodgers is an elite
quarterback so how can we how can we
entire circle if if he's not a lead
anymore then how come the coach of the
year isn't Lafleur right or like you
know it makes no sense and yet the
Darius Smith is the Defensive Player of
the Year candidate nobody talks about
right but I think it goes back to their
like the Vikings down the stretch that
defense which was strong in the
beginning the year was shaky at times we
saw Aaron Rodgers not the Aaron Rodgers
and you can say because he doesn't have
to be
they've got a running game now they're
more diverse and all that kind of stuff
but the last two games he missed throws
that Aaron Rodgers doesn't miss right
he missed open receivers that has
nothing to do with the design of the
offense something doesn't seem right
with him or on the field right didn't
seem like he was playing like the Aaron
Rodgers that we know the last couple of
weeks and I think those kinds of things
caused you to pause a little bit now all
that said who wants to go to Lambeau
Field in January you know it could be
zero degrees it's nobody twenty degree
it doesn't matter
so that also plays a factor but when you
look at their football team you go hmm
can't you see New Orleans going they're
winning next week New Order's wins this
week they have to go to green to stop
Aaron Jones nobody talks about that kid
either have you ever talked to him
multiple times unbelievable one of those
guys that should be the face
everybody's gonna be the face of that
franchise no question but he should be
one of the faces that people talk about
in this league nobody talks about
correct he's unbelievable fact but
anyway I think if you say okay New
Orleans wins this week they have to go
to Lambeau next week I don't care where
that game is I would take New Orleans I
mean I really would
so I just don't see Green Bay being that
team that's elite with the other other
you know top seeds well I chose the
Saints to win it all prior to the season
I'm gonna stick with it before we move
on to your your new show all I'm gonna
stick with that you are yeah
Chiefs over who I will say Chiefs over
San Francisco but I I keep saying the
Orleans MIT New Orleans scares me if I'm
San Francisco because they've got a goat
at the quarterback spot they've got one
of the greats that we've ever seen at
the wide receiver position got to see
San Francisco earlier and they've got a
defense and they've got a coach who's
the right amount of crazy yeah I mean
and we saw ten years ago in Miami and he
was new at that game pretty much then
and Sean Payton you know it's ten years
later and oh yeah that's why I say I
think the Saints are gonna win it all
let's talk about America's top dog here
just k-9 cop k-9 cops against civilian
dogs in a competition yes Knights all of
cable television is live PD Friday night
episode three hours Saturday night
episodes number one and two shows an all
basic cable so this is
spinoff of that they take one police k-9
dog yes from life PD along with three
other dogs from law enforcement agencies
around the country sheriff's departments
police departments yes and then we bring
in one civilian underdog and sometimes
it's a cocker spaniel it's a bulldog
it's a we've had a mastiff Rottweilers
but they're trained to compete against
these dogs they're gonna do everything
you go in and out of cars you climb
what's supposed to do is simulate what
they do in the field they jump over
fences they have to swim in the water
they have to get through the thicket
good good work there were thick bushes
current you know all kinds of things
that the dogs have to do in the field
when they're in the police yes pursuit
and then they have to take down a
suspect at the end with the bike so a
guy in the bite suit gets attacked in
the civilian dogs too including the
civilian dogs and they have to do that
in release they have to find different
scents in different locations so
civilian dogs have to do everybody has
to do the same thing but what is great
about it is that you see I think two
things that I love about this show one
that I'm doing it the other thing is
that you get to see the relationship
between the handlers and the dogs and
the handlers have to run the course with
the dogs so it's not just send your dog
out and go do it you got to go alongside
it and you can see the callin response
in the bond that they have but also I
think it's really important not only the
civilian under dogs can we understand
people we all have pets that we love and
we know how how we treat these dogs and
and how they respond to us but we rarely
see that with law enforcement dogs every
time you see a dog in a police chase
they're chasing down a suspect they're
angry they're biting they're on the hunt
these dogs are the pets of these law
enforcement officers often mhmm they
play with their kids we show that side
of the dogs as well and the relationship
and you get to see the officer smile and
the dogs are having fun and I think
that's a different angle that we don't
think about when we think about police
don't well when I was doing Thursday
night football every week would be on
and the guys Dianna always made fun of
me because every time I went through
security I would stop and say hello to
the dog
you know first you have to ask if it's
oh of course right because the dog is
working yes who protect us yeah and you
know you don't need some guy coming up
and just you know giving it what a
darling
know when they're working when they're
not right when they're out here they're
having fun you know it's not work time
it's it's it's a beautiful show I really
love it that's awesome and again it's on
Wednesday nights on A&E 9:00 Eastern and
Pacific and if you ever do host a show
where a dog has to destroy a toy
completely the second set that it or
eating absolutely anything whether it's
edible or not I've got two dogs for you
I've got two that will disobey any
command you want to give them as well
before I let you go Kurt earlier on in
this conversation you mentioned about
you know getting ready for Sunday's
games and how you're gonna be hyping up
one of one of the games right before cuz
promote a league right promoting well
he's correct yes and that you turn to me
and you said you know you know what it's
like hosting a one-hour pregame show and
I'll be honest with you Kurt I don't I
don't know what it's like to host a
one-hour showing you talked about this
in our little text on Sunday I mean it's
really not that hard it's the same thing
just repeat it over and over actually
every hour is its own unique fingerprint
in every segment is its own unique world
and fingerprint that requires the deft
touch of a host but listen when it all
comes down to it the Tirico sending out
this text about how wonderful it is to
work in this industry in our job and how
fortunate we all we all are and he is a
first-class individual 100% no doubt and
it is an outlier in our industry to have
people take the time to do that and
bring all of us tightly in a manner that
creates a community how did my response
of saying I'm sorry I'm just receiving
this I'm the only one who hosts a
four-hour show because nobody responded
to the very nice tags you know how we
walk into a room and you go wow there's
always one jerk in every room if you
have to ask it's usually you okay right
now I'm Hawk sitting you're jerk if you
have to ask why didn't I get a response
was it funny yeah usually you answered
your own question that's the point I
make what did you when did you receive
that text probably getting ready for
your one-hour show because it was in the
middle of the second of my four maybe no
one responded because we did not want to
interrupt you is all about you rich I
showed it to Kurt Warner who is as you
know an aces into yes sir
and he's like send it he said send it
[Music]
two hours you could respond sent right
back at you text and then followed it up
with the snark that if I went thanks for
the world we are thank you for having me
bro oh you got it man
have a great playoffs thank you you too
right back at and we'll see you in Miami
we'll see what if not before how long is
your pregame show in Miami
four hours
oh my god no one texted me during my
pregame show Super Bowl exists I'll do
that cuz I'm and I'll be an hour five
that's very important one that we also
do have half times and post games that
count in the time as well now half time
is really for you I mean it's just like
here's here's the act right here's well
JLo there's some analysis that goes on
yeah I'm sure there is a little bit that
and then of course the Potro fee
presentation all that kind of stuff yeah
when I say us my said Fox can't you do
this because I have to hold down the
fort while Terry does that okay mmm my
god it's a team effort brother by the
way just real quick story Terry and
Howie both came on to promote Fox NFL
Sunday at the Super Bowl in Jacksonville
Oh which I think predates you by years
yes okay
so they came on NFL Total Access were on
live television and we had the Lombardi
Trophy there is set dressing and I said
to Terry I'm like what's it like to pick
that up four times and he went to go
grab it and a member of security jumbo
in front of you that touch with alimony
I know and just seeing Terry's look on
his face is somebody prevented him for
such a trophy that he's won four times
exactly the only face more priceless was
how he's laughing you know I can only
imagine I'm shocked I heard that story
before that Super Bowl it was the last
one that Fox did you know before I got
there right but that was when they
appalled McCartney on a live show and
President Bush George W George HW maybe
they had both George HW for sure for
sure yes that was George HW Bush and
Bill Clinton together that's why there
it is also Paul McCartney that's the
pregame show well at least you got four
hours to make up for a very good
I'll be there as US America's top dog on
A&E every Wednesday starting January 8th
9 Eastern and Pacific and then of course
Fox NFL Sunday good to see you Kurt
always great to see the daughter for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app